good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight peter navarro is the
picture of a law abiding american
citizen he's a 72 year old retired
business school professor he's got a phd
in economics from harvard university his
most recent job was extremely white
collar he served at the as the white
house trade advisor in the last
presidential administration
famous for his tough stance on china
he's never been charged with a crime
he's never trafficked fentanyl for
example from mexico in fact his hobby is
yoga and riding his bicycle in short
peter navarro does not seem like a
criminal much less a danger to this
nation and yet last friday federal
agents arrested peter navarro at reagan
national airport in washington
they did not call his lawyer as his
customary in cases like this they didn't
even come to his house which as it
happens is just feet from the fbi
building they could have walked but they
didn't
instead they took down peter navarro in
public as you would a fugitive terror
mastermind so everyone could see it and
learn the lesson they were sending they
handcuffed peter navarro they put him in
leg irons and then they threw them him
in a cell he's now facing years in
prison
so what did peter navarro do to deserve
treatment like this well he resisted a
subpoena from the january 6th committee
the january 6 committee is washington's
latest partisan inquisition it's run by
nancy pelosi with help from obedient
little quizlings like liz cheney and
adam kinzinger
navarro resisted that subpoena because
he had nothing to do with january 6th
nothing whatsoever that's not disputed
peter navarro did not break into the
capital he didn't encourage anyone else
to break into the capital he wasn't even
there that day he had no idea it was
going to happen again that's beyond
dispute and nancy pelosi and liz cheney
know that
if you really wanted to figure out what
happened on january 6 peter navarro
would be the last person you would talk
to instead you'd be talking to rayapps
and various fbi informants
but finding out what happened on january
6 and why is not the point of the
exercise the point of the exercise
is preventing donald trump from running
for president again
so in the service of that goal pelosi
and liz cheney demanded that peter
navarro surrender records of his private
conversations with his former boss
president donald trump
and when he refused to do that congress
voted to hold him in contempt in a
partisan vote and then merrick garland's
justice department filed criminal
charges against peter nefaro
this is not the way civilized countries
operate
just because you control the white house
in both houses of congress does not mean
you get to throw your political
opponents behind bars
that's not what we do in america that's
what they do in haiti
but that's what we're doing now and
peter navarro is not the first biden's
justice department also arrested former
trump adviser steve bannon for a similar
fake crime steve bannon is awaiting
trial this summer
so this is not something we've seen
before it's a huge step toward the
politics of the third world
but the media whose job you thought it
was to push back against power are not
they're in fact applauding because it
turns out no punishment is too severe
for those who disagree with the national
news media
watch them gloat
what happened to peter navarro is what
should have happened to peter navarro he
was indicted and when you're indicted
you're arrested what peter navarro did
it was so far out of bounds so
indefensible this prosecution is really
about punishing navarro based on his
latent disrespect for the congressional
subpoena
so they really are your enemies they're
not covering the news they're plotting
ways to hurt you that's true
congratulations are not optional they
lecture you comply with them or go to
jail that's the message the lawyers on
television are sending so let's pretend
for a moment that that was true though
it's in fact not true
if there was in fact a law like that for
that law to be legitimate it would have
to be like all laws applied equally
across the board and no less than the
attorney general himself has said that
again and again and again i came to work
here he said because we're committed to
the rule of law and to seeking equal
justice under the law that was merrick
garland in january quote we conduct
every investigation guided by the same
norms
now those are the norms under which this
country has lived for 250 years it's not
justice unless it's applied equally to
all adult american citizens period
anything less than that is by definition
not justice
but we're getting much less than that
and it's very obvious here's just one
example
10 years ago this month congress voted
overwhelmingly on a bipartisan vote vote
by the way 17 democrats to hold eric
holder then the attorney general in
criminal contempt of congress
holder had refused to turn over
documents showing how the obama
administration had armed the mexican
drug cartels do you remember that
one of the firearms they sent to mexico
into the so-called fast and furious
program was then used to murder a u.s
border patrol officer it was a scandal
at the time in case you don't recall
watch
border patrol agent brian terry died in
december 2010 killed by guns tied to an
obama administration plan that armed
mexicans a scandal officials tried to
hide by wrongly claiming executive
privilege emails contained in the house
oversight committee's report show top
officials knew the atf sent guns to
mexico even before terry's death even
the border patrol which sent terry's
team into the desert didn't know about
the operation
so that was a legitimate scandal
that implicated the entire us government
people who actually have power not the
retirees sitting in jail because of what
they did on january 6th but people with
actual power and eric holder was the
very center of it but a holder refused
to comply with a subpoena from the
congress did the fbi arrest eric holder
for that please it was never even
seriously considered holder asserted
executive privilege the right to have
conversations with the executive the
president that are private
he cited the long-standing policy of
respecting executive privilege
and he got away with it
so a week ago peter navarro made this
exact point he sued the justice
department pushing back against this
subpoena four days before he was
arrested and in that suit navarro cited
policy written by the doj's office of
legal counsel that policy reads this way
quote
since the 1970s this office has
consistently advised that the president
and his immediate advisers are
absolutely immune from testimonial
compulsion by congressional committee on
matters related to their official duties
end quote
in other words if somebody asserts
executive privilege at the very least
congress doesn't get to arrest them
before anyone is arrested they have to
go to a judge to rule on whether or not
executive privilege is valid in this
case and that's exactly what happened in
eric holder's case and by the way the
federal judge rejected eric holder's
executive privilege claim and still he
was not arrested why
you know why
because he's a leading democrat
but in peter navarro's case merrick
garland's doj did not even bother to ask
a judge they just arrested peter navarro
at national airport
so what we're seeing here isn't really
about peter navarro or steve bannon what
we're seeing is a massive escalation
in the use by the democratic party of
our justice system
for partisan revenge
that's exactly what that was peter
navarro wouldn't shut up so they threw
him in handcuffs
and in fact at the same moment peter
navarro was thrown in jail for asserting
executive privilege a clinton lawyer
called michael sussman was acquitted by
a jury seated by an obama appointed
judge three of the jurors in that case
gave money to hillary clinton's campaign
and not surprisingly those same jurors
declined to punish michael sussman for
lying to the fbi to advance the russia
collusion myth that helped hillary
clinton's campaign following all this
how does jurors get on the jury how they
stay there
now the fbi pretended to be outraged by
the fact that michael sussman had lied
to them but then we learned actually the
fbi was working with michael sussman and
his law firm perkins coy
perkins coy had an fbi workspace in its
offices in washington for a decade and
michael sussman was so close to the fbi
he had a key card to fbi headquarters we
know this from a recently released text
exchange we're quoting do you have a
badge or do you need help getting into
the building the fbi's general counsel
james baker asked sussman and we're
quoting now i have a badge sussman
replied
susman had a badge to the fbi building
how do we get one of those oh
we're not leading democratic lawyers so
we can't have them
so michael sussman knew he'd never be
punished
take three steps back what's going on
here in a fantastic peace state the
federalist ben weingarten explained
how we should understand these two
prosecutions quote they send an
unmistakable message we can get you
anytime anywhere on any grounds we
choose you can't touch even a single one
of ours
that's it right there this is a partisan
play
by a political party that has somehow
completely taken over our lodge's
largest law enforcement agency and
andrew sussman is not michael sussman is
not even
the biggest example of this andrew
mccabe lisa page peter strzok all of
them lied to the feds as well that's a
crime
none of them were ever hauled off in leg
irons in fact they're now at cnn msnbc
and georgetown respectively they were
rewarded with better jobs for what they
did they always are
jim clapper and john brennan committed
perjury on television before congress
there's no dispute about that what do
they do oh they're on tv now too
hunter biden lied on a federal gun form
that's a felony
how was he punished oh a mild probing on
cbs that he just shrugged off as if it
were nothing watch
why did you have a gun
well i did again you know the period of
my life that um
was difficult it was um
but
you know i i don't know
according to the reporting at one point
the secret service went
looking for the record of sale do you
know anything about that nothing no but
you know about the secret service being
involved no i had no idea i don't know
whether the secret service were or why
they would be or i don't think that
that's true
i don't know why the secret service were
involved really you had no idea because
they were with you
they helped you
you committed a gun felony
it's all out there
but hunter biden is the president's son
and more importantly he's a faithful
party loyalist so you know as well as he
does he doesn't have a thing to worry
about in fact he can flaunt his crimes
radaronline.com just got pictures of
hunter biden casually waving his illegal
firearm around as he voted with a
prostitute several years ago
the pictures show hunter biden's finger
on the trigger of the gun as well as
crack cocaine and drug paraphernalia hmm
a weapon of war in the hands of a drug
addict
is the justice department bothered by
this no of course not
you know what bothers the justice
department quite a bit defying the
democratic party do that and your house
gets raided by a swat team that tips off
cnn before it happens
roger stone discovered that the hard way
exclusive footage
you're looking at right now from cnn as
the fbi arrives at roger stone's
residence in fort lauderdale florida
taking him into custody they arrived
before dawn there before 6a or just
after 6 a.m a dozen officers were told
so that's the actual norm if you were
tony podesta and you work for the
democratic party you're totally fine
nothing you do is going to get you in
trouble and you know it if you're roger
stone you've done nothing wrong at all
but you've given the finger to the
democratic party they show up at your
house with guns that's the norm the
attorney general is upholding
serve the democratic party and you will
be rewarded even if you're a felon
at almost exactly the moment the doj was
putting peter navarro in shackles the
doj was also dropping the most serious
charges against the two left-wing
lawyers who tried to incinerate cops
burn them to death in their patrol cars
during the blm riots now this pair had
faced 30 years in jail on terrorism
charges but that was too tough for the
biden doj they'll be out in a couple max
why because they've got the right
politics and liz cheney's not giving you
a lecture about people who try to burn
police officers to death are a threat to
our democracy now they're fine we're
just going to ignore them it never
happened
this happens all the time in california
at the height of the blm riots a career
felon called tony walker executed a 19
year old berkeley student called seth
smith walked up for no reason never seen
him before in his life and executed him
fired a gun into the back of his head
why do you do this because of his skin
color it was a racially motivated attack
f that white m effort walker said no one
denies that he said that
but here's the interesting thing a guy's
just executed on the street because he's
got the wrong skin color sounds like a
hate crime right
no
merrick garland's doj did not
pursue hate crime charges in fact a
month ago prosecutors caught an
unbelievable deal with walker they
sentenced him on a single charge of
brace yourself
voluntary manslaughter f that white m
effort he said is he executed a college
student that sounds like voluntary
manslaughter
this is a dangerous trend and not just
because people are dying
nothing destroys the legitimacy of our
institutions more than politicized law
enforcement you can't have that justice
must be blind if there is a single
institution we have to preserve for the
sake of our children and grandchildren
it's our justice system and the law
enforcement agencies that serve it they
can't be corrupt if they're corrupt it's
going to be pretty hard to live here
liz cheney and nancy pelosi and the rest
of the lunatics on the january 6
committee have done far more damage to
this democracy than the rioters ever did
far more another trying to make it worse
axios is reporting that some members of
the committee quote want big changes on
voting rights and even to abolish the
electoral college
abolishing the electoral college
and if you're against that of course
you're undermining democracy
was it a conspiracy i think certainly i
mean look if you you look at the court
filings um you believe it it was a
conspiracy i do
it is extremely broad
it's extremely well organized it's
really chilling
oh it's really chilling what's really
chilling is when the committee gets to
arrest people not because they violated
meaningful laws or pose a threat to the
united states
but because
their politics
are unacceptable
because they have given the finger to
people like liz cheney is liz cheney
okay with that the upholder of democracy
we texted liz cheney on friday and said
are you okay with that with this they
just arrested a 72 year old man who did
nothing wrong doesn't that cross some
kind of line are you going to stand up
and say something about it
she didn't respond
the january 6 committee has just hired a
former producer of good morning america
called james goldston he'll be
overseeing the committee's prime time
hearings on thursday night so the show
trial now has a production crew and of
course we'll be covering that in great
detail on thursday
by arresting peter navarro they're
hoping to shut up one of the most vocal
critics before it begins
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight